this video was made possible by
Squarespace build your beautiful website
for 10% off at squarespace.com slash
Wendover according to conventional
economic rules casinos shouldn't be able
to exist
that's because conventional economic
rules assume humans are rational
conventional economic rules would
predict that if someone offered you a
deal where you gave them $100 and they
gave you 94 dollars and 80 cents back
you wouldn't take that deal but for some
strange reason perfectly intelligent
people head to the roulette table every
day and in essence take that exact deal
just look an American roulette table has
38 numbers on it double 0 0 & 1 through
36 the best odds on the table are in the
red black even and odd boxes if you put
a $5 chip in the red box for example and
the ball falls on a red number you
double your money you gain 5 dollars but
of course the ball can fall on 0 or
double 0 which are neither red nor black
and for these purposes neither even nor
odd now if the zero and double zero
didn't exist then playing roulette would
make perfect sense if you came in with
$100 and played infinite times you would
leave with $100 because it would be a
50% chance of doubling your money each
time in reality because of those zeros
the odds of doubling your money are
actually 47.4%
that means that for every dollar you
play you can expect to lose 5.2 cents
but for some reason people still do it
while this small gap in between fair
odds and the odds casinos and other
gambling institutions offer earn them
worldwide close to half a trillion
dollars per year but consider this for
the same reason gambling shouldn't work
insurance also shouldn't insurance is
essentially the exact opposite of
gambling insurance companies are
basically gambling companies but the
roles are flipped the insurance
companies are the gamblers and you're
the casino if you pay a car insurance
company for example $1500 a year to
ensure your vehicle they're gambling
that you're not going to cause more than
$1,500 in coverable damage in any one
year but of course it takes money to run
the insurance company so they need a
margin MetLife one of the world's
largest insurance companies for example
takes in thirty seven point two billion
from the people who hold insurance
policies with them but then pay back in
insurance claims just thirty
6.35 billion of course there are other
sources of revenue and other expenses at
MetLife but just looking at the balance
between what comes in and what goes out
for insurance the odds are pretty decent
compared to the roulette wheel for every
dollar you give them you can expect to
get about ninety seven point seven cents
back but that's still losing money
according to the same conventional
economic rules that say that casinos
shouldn't be able to exist insurance
companies to just shouldn't work as a
concept because people get back less and
they put in but here's why they do just
consider this would you rather with 100%
certainty receive five dollars or would
you rather have an eighty percent chance
of receiving six dollars and twenty five
cents feel free to think about it for a
second but chances are that you said
that you'd rather have that sure five
dollars when surveyed with this question
over three-quarters of respondents said
that they wanted the certain five
dollars over the 80% chance of six
dollars and twenty five cents but here's
the strange thing these two options are
worth the exact same amounts if you took
the eighty percent gamble infinite times
you would receive an average of five
dollars each time as 80 percent of 625
is five therefore in theory people
should have no preference between these
two options because they're worth the
exact same amount but here's the thing
people in general dislike losing a given
amount of money more than they like
winning it that is the negative effect
of losing five dollars for example is
greater than the positive effect of
winning five dollars because the second
option comes with the chance of loss
which is a negative experience more
powerful than the positive experience of
certainly gaining five dollars this
option is worth less overall even if
it's worth the same in a dollar amount
this is why insurance works insurance is
a worthwhile gamble for the insurance
company since the odds are in their
favor and they make money while the
gamble is worth it for you because the
monetary amount you get back plus the
absence of monetary loss make the deal
worth more than the money you put in
overall of course it is a bit more
complicated than this since insurance
companies often have preferential rates
for health care and it helps smooth out
economic shocks so despite being a
gamble it is absolutely worth it in most
cases but insurance at its most basic
level is losing
to avoid loss the principle of hating
losing can be used to make the same
amount of money worth more in one
experiment 150 teachers in Chicago
Heights were split up into three groups
one group received nothing one was told
that they would receive a bonus at the
end of the year corresponding to how
well the students test scores were and
the third group was given the exact same
deal for a bonus with the only
difference being that they were given
the bonus payment upfront at the
beginning of the year and told that they
would have to pay back the corresponding
amount if their students did not score
the test scores necessary the group that
was promised the bonus if test scores
improved performed largely the same as
the group offered no bonus but the group
given the bonus up front
overall performed much better with test
scores improving up to three times as
much as the traditional bonus group it's
clear that the fear of loss is far more
powerful than the promise of gain so
this explains why insurance works but
for the same reason
gambling still shouldn't work but
something interesting starts changing
when you change the odds now remember
that three-quarters of people preferred
a sure five dollars to an 80% chance of
625 but now think whether you prefer on
a hundred percent chance of receiving
five dollars or a 25 percent chance of
winning twenty dollars once again the
options are worth the exact same amount
since twenty five percent of twenty is
five dollars but with this change of
odds those surveyed on average had no
preference between the two options half
preferred the sure five dollars and the
other half preferred a 25% chance of
twenty dollars the let's changed the
odds again would you prefer on a hundred
percent chance of receiving five dollars
or a point five percent chance of
winning one thousand dollars still with
these numbers 0.5% of 1,000 is five
dollars so the two options are worth the
exact same amount but with these options
for the first time people prefer the
gamble only 36 percent of respondents
said that they would take the five
dollars while 64 percent preferred the
half percent chance of winning $1,000
will we begun to understand is that
humans like low probability risk we like
a small chance of winning big over a
certain game in fact you can see this at
the racetrack the best horse might have
two-to-one odds where you get three
dollars if they win for each dollar you
bet while the
horse might have 200 to 1 odds where you
get $300 if they win for each dollar you
bet but as it turns out on average the
chance of the top horse winning is
actually better than 2 to 1 and the
chance of the bottom horse winning is
the worse than 200 to 1 because people
prefer betting on the underdog which
inflates the odds you could therefore
make more money betting on the horse
that's likeliest to win crunching the
betting data from 8,000 tennis matches
it was found that the bets on the best
athletes with the best odds actually
made money on average with 103 percent
of the money won back while the bets on
the worst athletes with the worst odds
won just 81 percent of the money back
evidence for this phenomenon has been
found time and time again but the
question of why we do it is tougher the
simple answer for why this is is that
people overweight the impact and chances
of extremely low probability events this
has been used to explain why people are
so afraid of terrorism and plane crashes
despite the chances of dying of either
being monumentally small it really
doesn't matter if you know that the odds
are not in your favor like with the
lottery or in the casino people still
love risk if it comes with large returns
and this is why gambling works as a
concept everyone just has some arbitrary
points we're given two options with the
same value they'll start accepting the
risk over the sure money what that means
is that in a gambling transaction with
someone who bets and someone who accepts
the bet both parties actually find what
they're doing worth while the casino
finds what they're doing worthwhile
because they make money well the better
because they have the possibility of
winning lots of money now the
explanation for why people prefer these
low probability bets moves further away
from economics into psychology but one
explanation with the lottery for example
is that a bet doubling one's money does
a little to change one's quality of life
but a bet multiplying a person's money
by a factor of thousands can be truly
life-changing so people are betting for
monumental change rather than for
another cup of coffee to summarize what
this all means is that a 5 percent
chance of 100 dollars is worth more to
people than 5 dollars
despite both having a monetary value of
5 dollars therefore by offering Gamble's
people can make money more powerful
almost everywhere in the world there's
an issue of low savings rates people
don't put an
money into banks about half of Americans
could not immediately come up with
$2,000 if an unexpected expense came up
according to one survey a big reason for
this lack of savings is that banks are
not incentivizing enough with how tiny
savings accounts interest rates are many
people just don't see a reason to put
their money in banks and banks are
unwilling or financially can't increase
their interest rates so how do you make
the same amount of money go further you
turn it into a gamble Economist's
created a concept for what's called a
prize linked savings account a normal
savings account with $2,000 in it at a
bank that offered 1% annual interest
would earn $20.00 a year but with a
prize linked savings account instead of
being given the $20 in interest it would
be entered into a gamble with for
example 0.4 percent chance of winning
$5,000 as always that gamble is still
worth $20 monetarily but to the gambler
it's worth more
these prize linked savings accounts have
been incredibly successful at getting
people to save in Michigan's trial of
the system 56% of those using it were
first time savers these same principles
are the ones that make lotteries work in
fact lotteries are just such easy ways
of making money that in many countries
privately run lotteries are illegal in
the US for example all lotteries have to
be state-run and their profits usually
go to funding education because the
states are guaranteed to make money from
the lottery it is essentially a form of
taxation in fact all forms of gambling
are set up in a way that they're
guaranteed to make money for whoever's
running them in a casino at a racetrack
or with any form of gambling it's never
a good deal for the better but the
reason why people engage in these deals
is a fascinating study of behavioral
economics and its principles if applied
correctly can sometimes just maybe be
used for good what's also a good deal
though is Squarespace that's because if
you're running any sort of business your
first impression counts immensely and
Squarespace helps you build the perfect
first impression no matter how small
your business is it's absolutely crucial
to have a website but of course it's
expensive to hire someone to create one
and complicated to code one yourself
Squarespace makes it all easy with
customisable designer templates an
easy-to-use website builder 24/7 award
winning customer support and reasonable
prices the
sites can have plenty of features like a
blog video pages an online store and
more you can try squarespace out for
free at squarespace.com slash Wendover
and then when you're ready to launch you
can use the code Wendover for 10% off
your first website or domain purchase